a flow is technically defined as an
optimal state of consciousness a state
of consciousness where we feel our best
and we perform our best it refers to
those moments of total absorption when
we get so focused on the task at hand
that everything else disappears so our
sense of self our sense of
self-consciousness they vanish time
dilates which means sometimes it slows
down you get that freeze-frame effect
familiar denim you seen the matrix I've
been in a car crash
sometimes it speeds up in five hours
will pass by in like five minutes and
throughout all aspects of performance so
mental and physical go through the roof
underneath the flow state is a kind of
complicated mass of neurobiology there
are fundamental changes in neural
anatomy which is where in the brain
something's taking place neural
chemistry and/or electricity which is
the two ways the brain communicates with
itself the most prominent is the neural
anatomical changes so the old idea about
ultimate performance flow is what's
known as a 10% brain map the idea that
we're only using 10% of our brain at any
one time so ultimate performance must
obviously be the full brain firing on
all cylinders and it turns out we had it
exactly backwards in flow parts of the
brain aren't becoming more hyperactive
they're actually slowing down shutting
down the technical term for this is
transient meaning temporary
hypofrontality hypo Hyp OS the opposite
of hyper means to slow down to shut down
to deactivate and frontality is the
prefrontal cortex the part of your brain
that houses your higher cognitive
functions your sense of morality your
sense of will your sense of self all
that shuts down so for example why does
time pass so strangely in flow because
David Eagleman discover the time is
calculated all over the prefrontal
cortex parts would start to wink out we
can no longer separate paths from
present and future were plunged into
what researchers called a deep now
transient hypofrontality is interesting
it was discovered back in the 90s and
had very negative connotations it was
found in schizophrenic sand drug addicts
and then in the early thousands our
Dietrich who was then at Georgia Tech
discovered or hypothesized that
hypofrontality actually underpins every
altered state dreaming meditation flow
drug addiction doesn't really matter
and then in 2007-2008 charles lim at
johns hopkins working with first jazz
musicians and second with rappers was
looking at flow in those context and
found that the prefrontal cortex was
shutting down as well though depending
on the altered state you get different
different parts are shut down like in
flow one of the most prominent examples
is the dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex
shuts down flow this is the part of the
brain that houses your inner critic that
nagging the fetus always on voice in
your head turns off and flow and as a
result we feel this is liberation right
we're finally getting out of our own way
we're free of ourselves creativity goes
up risk-taking goes up and we feel
amazing the project the flow Genome
Project my mission for the past 15 years
has been started to reclaim flow
research from the hippy community from
the New Age community and put it back on
a really hard science footing and really
what that took was flow research has
been going on continuously at kind of
both here in the United States and
Europe all over and it really just took
synthesizing all the information and
bringing it together and putting it on a
hard neurobiological footing that said
there's a bunch left to do right we have
a hundred fifty years of flow psychology
and flow science goes back all the way
to the 1870s in fact some of the
earliest experiments ever run in kind of
early neuroscience and early kind of
Experimental Psychology were run on flow
we're done on flow in the past 25 years
as our brain imaging technology has
gotten better and better and better we
can look farther into the brain and see
what's going on we've got about 25 years
of neurobiology that's underpinning and
I sort of think it starts with dr.
Andrew Newberg at the University of
Pennsylvania who was looking he was
actually looking at spiritual
experiences in meditating Tibetan
Buddhists and Franciscan nuns and he
found that quote unquote state of cosmic
unity when we become one with everything
is actually a byproduct of Tran
hypofrontality as well what happens when
the type of front heli moves out of the
prefrontal cortex and back into the
right parietal lobe which is the part of
the brain that separates self or mother
right it allows us to walk through
crowded rooms without bumping into
people and things along those lines in
flow or any kind of deep focused
attention this portion of the brain
shuts down so we can no longer separate
myself from others so when people talk
about feeling one with everything
you'll get it in action sports surface
will talk about being one with the waves
mountain climbers one with the mountain
whatever it is for buddhists it's cosmic
unity it's one with the universe but
what's really happening is the portion
of the brain that's separate itself from
other is shut down so we can no longer
distinguish between the two things and
as a result we feel one with everything